nous sommes en direct avec massimo nava
éditorialiste au corriere della serra
bonsoir monnaie va merci d'être avec
nous alors c'était non sein du port du
masque obligatoire dans les lieux
publics à partir de 18 heures
c'est une annonce forte est ce qu'elles
étaient indispensables on regarde les
chiffres on sait de la prévention pur
c'est évidemment de la prévention c'est
indispensable
le nombre des gens qui sont affectées 1
ce moment c'est très très faible c'est
pas les nobles qui enregistre en ce
moment en france par exemple
mais ces moments les gouvernements ont
toujours choisi début de l'épidémie la
ligue et l'applaudissent la lignée de la
prévention est donc un ferme et le bois
des mythes et à fermer aussi appelé
aussi des mesures très strictes pour 20
le rassemblement d'aller dans les lieux
publics dans un espèce de course yeux
qui a évidemment suscité beaucoup des
pique niques dans le milieu politique
dans les catégories infectés de cette
problème tous les bois de nous des
lamantins de presque 400 millions
d'euros et peut pas empêcher les gens
sous tous les jeunes des dessins des cld
s'est rassemblée dans les places de
plage ce moment des vacances de tourisme
10 et donc c'est vraiment montrer très
très compliqué mais je pense que c'est
aussi la ligne du gouvernement qui a
préservé la brise petit bip risquer la
responsabilité d'aider les décisions à
la science avec ses pertes et donc tous
les experts sont cons chrono d'hier qui
ferait tout dans ce qu'est un rôle a
vraiment la peur d'une nouvelle vague
il est même après les vacances les
touristes qui reviennent
lieu déjà tous là les trajets un peu des
migrants aussi qui débarquent en sicile
donc il ya un et surtout les grains
pointait locative un saignement c'est
d'ailleurs dans toutes les écoles donc
qu'est-ce qu'on peut c'est un coup
empêché kelly qui reprend de santé s'ils
voient des mois est ce qu a eue c'est
une réponse aussi à certains
comportements peut-être voilà abusif on
a vu ça en france on parle beaucoup de
saint tropez des boîtes de nuit en plein
air on voit les gens sont sont collées
entre ce que ça a été le cas en italie
on a souvent décrit une venise vide
florence vide également est ce qu'il ya
des lieux où il ya eu certains abus
peut-être d'où cette réponse du
gouvernement c'est un peu le caractère
universel de la jeunesse si vous voulez
et surtout en italie après trois voire
quatre mois des l'occident très strictes
c'est évident qu'ils aient un sens de
délibérations mais il faut pas
généraliser parce qu'il s'agit d'hommes
tous les cas des minots des minorités et
donc les comportements dire que samson
la majorité des italiennes et aussi de
jeunes de jeunes les mains qui le
problème c'est que tout le monde a
apporté pour avoir un nouvelle vague
dans les prochaines d'être chassé mans
surtout avec la saison plus voir partir
de moi c'est stable autour de la salle a
pu voir et donc les diam's peut
reprendre le samsonov et si tu es un
puce on peut veulent autoriser italien
dans le souvenir que les hôpital et
stout sanitaire invs italienne même ces
deux systèmes s'invite à l'italienne
s'est toujours considéré plan allait
première place dans le monde
on n'est pas très sains à son bord d un
nouvelle vague des malades dans les
hôpitaux donc oui le gouvernement
pardonnez moi de vous couper cas où
clairement le gouvernement aujourd'hui a
fait le choix de la sécurité puisque on
sait que l'italie souffre beaucoup à l'e
tourisme on a vu beaucoup de reportages
elle disait à venise vide
florence des grands villes emblématiques
ils sont normalement remplis de
touristes qui l'avait jamais vu ça ce
qu'il faut craindre encore plus pour une
de la fuite du tourisme après après ces
annonces parce qu'on sait que ça fait
peur voilà le masque est pas 18h et ses
terrasses que clairement il ya une
crainte
ben si vous pouvez m'aider à il ya un
peu un arrière-pensée évidemment le
gouvernement a choisi la moitié doubt à
tapas de ces décisions-là peuple il
était donc à laisser un peu là c'est
faire un peu des vacances un peu des
libertés et où règne un souci de
position plus stricte et mais
naturellement il faut comprendre la
grande question aujourd'hui c'est
j'espère qu'elle limite peut tenir la
population le sentiment que les ti vct 7
septime ans de peur des contrôles
stricts que des imitations de la liberté
enfin merci merci massimo nava
rappellera que vous êtes éditorialistes
merci d'avoir été avec moi